sir welcome thank you for having me
thanks for coming man first of all
welcome to La you're a new La resident
yep y very new very fresh what obviously
you have uh you've been in Illinois MH
um what motivated you to finally kind of
make the jump to the big times and come
over here and pay all this tax money
yeah you know hey I'm buckling up for my
first uh my first little tax return out
here but um
not really turn you don't get nothing
back you know what I mean um um but
honestly it was mainly two things a you
know the content I already come out here
you know I was traveling out here so
much to hang out with my friends do
podcast you know do that kind of stuff
um with the kind of stuff I do you know
making videos that kind of thing um it's
like a no-brainer to get out here
because the Illinois weed Market I don't
know if you know what's on about it
brutal is it brutal in terms of
legalities or just so it's legal but
they have at least in my opinion one of
the worst programs in the state they um
they campaigned it on like all this
social equity and like oh we're going to
you know give you know low income and
people who have been impacted by laws
licenses the first opportunity to see
yeah yeah the first chance and what it
ended up being was you know the the cost
to apply a loan was like $250,000 even
if you got denied so immediately so you
had to come up with 250 Grand just to
app cash apply and then if they say no
you're you're out of 250 yeah so
immediately the the 99.9% of people that
were supposed to benefit from it don't
qualify right yeah they're yeah yeah and
the 0.01% that do qualify got investors
for it right you know so the market out
there is just a bunch of like the big
companies that came out from the east
coast and you know all the corporations
and just put a bunch on the shelf and
then the taxes the taxes are crazy yeah
I don't even like um I guess being in La
I don't really go to dispensaries yeah
yeah yeah it's different I guess I'm I'm
kind of like I get a bunch of free which
you do I'm sure so it's
like you know I don't know yeah shout
out to the folks paying and listen shout
out to the dispensaries I heard it is a
extremely like the like to be in Cali
and be on that side of the business I
heard is very tough tough cuz the black
market is still where all the money is
as a matter of fact a lot of these guys
are doing both yeah as they should be oh
they're all backdooring 99% of them are
backdooring dude I mean I you know it's
funny because doing what I do and going
to all these events and like networking
and stuff you you shake hands with these
people and you know you you only know
them prior to that from the dispensary
shelf and you think like oh these guys
are super legit they're servant packs
right there to anybody you know it
doesn't they're all doing it it doesn't
matter biggest brand you can think of
shake a dude's hand get him on Instagram
all of a sudden you got a telegram get
whatever the f you want you know what
say yeah the telegram is crazy it's nuts
it's nuts but yeah um so they don't have
seses and out there oh no I mean they
have like some kind of they're either
super corporate or they're super lowkey
and super sketch super scuffed you know
in the neighborhood parking like empty
your car take the cups out type you know
so there's there's no real room for like
the market to grow there just because
the laws in the black market they got
some contenders you know there's Brands
like Capone's Garden putting out some
fire out there but that's like the only
one that comes to mind sadly that's
interesting so when you go to like cuz
for people who don't know if in LA
there's I mean probably once a week you
can find a dope me event to go to for
sure like twice a month oh yeah and
there's these giant seshes where you
know they're I don't know how legal or
illegal they are but the cops don't give
a cuz they're out front so you can walk
through and buy packs you could buy um
the last time I went to a sesh I
got uh this spray I've seen that going
around it almost comes like it looks
like a little bottle of Mace almost like
banaka almost when I went to the um
puffco just recently launched a new uh
like a new device or whatever and I went
to their event and there was some dude
going around I'm not going to name the
guy but there's some dude going around
just offering people sprays like y you
want a little spray where did that even
come from I don't know but it's not bad
yeah no it's not it's it's light it's
super light I haven't tried them but you
know I haven't done I in a couple years
you know I switched to the shs now but
um if I was still into theet I'd be
abusing are you going to the isn't
puffco Fest coming next pucon puff con
isn't that coming with like Action
Bronson and yeah they got a bunch of
people uh yeah I'm probably going I mean
I haven't feels like the kind of thing
you should be at yeah I mean I haven't
like booked a ticket yet but I mean
puffco they're the homies you know they
always you know hit me up they're like
yeah got a bunch of cool devices yeah
yeah they're dope they're dope